هلا الامين العام لحين في شمال الاطلسيه
نستوطن برج ان الحلفه لا يمكن ان يسمح
للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بالانتصار
في اوكرانيا لان ذلك سيظهر لي زعماء
الانظمه الاستبداديه حول العالم ان
بامكانهم تحقيق اهدافهم باستخدام القوه
في رومانيا ناقش الامن في منطقه البحر
الاسود وسبل زياده الدعم لاوكرانيا الحلف
الاخرين الذين يواجهون ضغوطوتا من موسكو
البحر الاسود ذات اهميه الاستراتيجيه لحلف
النيتكل والتحديات التي تطرحها الحرب
الروسيه غير القانونيه على اوكرانيه وردا
على العدوان الروسي يعيد الميت تعزيز
وجودهم من البطيخ الى البحر الاسود قد
شكلنا مجموعات قتاليه جديده بما في ذلك
تلك التي خذها فرنسا هنا في رومانيا في
بوخارست سيبحث وزراء خارجيه حلف الناتو
شبل زياده دعمنا لاوكرانيا والاشركاه
اخرين يواجهون ضغوطا روسيه كالبسمه
والهرسك وجورجيا ومولدافيا لا يمكننا
السماح لبوتين بالانتصار هذا سيظهر لزعماء
الانظمه الاستبداديه انه بامكانهم تحقيق
اهدافهم باستخدام القوه وجعل العالم اكثر
خطرا علينا جميعا